president trump and kim jong-un are
meeting in vietnam did you know that
wow no one seems to care
that's the most apathetic response ever
they were more excited about catching
yay hey screw world peace we like maya
make-believe yay that's a big story yes
uh this is in the news that president
trump was greeted he was greeted in
vietnam with a giant portrait of himself
yeah trump said hey put that back in my
bedroom come on
that goes on the ceiling uh
i should talk i have one um no it's of
me not of trump
kim jong-un arrived at the summit via a
train ride that took almost 70 hours
70 hours yes in other words they do have
amtrak
in vietnam so thank you thank you very
much
so far reports out of vietnam say trump
and kim jong-un are getting along
very very well yeah apparently they just
reenacted the bradley cooper
lady gaga duet face to face
tell me something girl as i said
i want to mention this because this is
worth showing i'm fascinated every time
i've seen this
kim jong-un arrived in vietnam for the
summit
with president trump and as always his
personal limousine is accompanied by
those bodyguards that jog along the
vehicle they jog alongside the vehicle
no one else does it like that it's
pretty crazy check it out this is check
it out
yeah well anyway that happened
that's him in vietnam what you don't
know is that kim jong-un got to vietnam
by train we have footage of that trip
yeah and then uh thank you that was big
of you and then
no then he's then he's going to go back
to north korea on a jet and that's the
important part